Hey hey what are you chewing on you feel
so funny ready yeah
in honor Sasha party I'm showing the
people of New York that our food has
feelings
hey what's up oh hey just grab my face
that is really butter are you hit eat my
friends and family you're not my type
good are you eating my nephew yeah oh no
don't do it put it down no way
bit him out what are your names
turn it in Justin more booze Jonathan
Justin and Marcos you sound like a
terrible boyband I love your fried
chicken sir it's delicious
what are you guys looking at is there
something more interesting than a
talking cantaloupe over there
Hey hey tiny yeah that's right
you reaching for stove top oh yeah what
a droid buddy the bird is talking to me
hey did you get scared are you scared a
little piece of bread grow a pair
I want you to watch what you watch so a
mom don't go mama that's gonna go
straight to you actually love sausage
I've been come on have you read a
sausage before no I'm not a cannibal
have you ever eaten the hipster how many
it's too sweet
it's a fake sausage so well you're
talking to it so how they can buy then
alright guys not that big but I'm
looking to eat though hearing it don't
eat cantaloupe you got it but can I
steal break eat all the grapes you want
think it's the grapes
um do you look for my sausages okay
buh-bam sausage party rated R for strong
crude sexual content pervasive life the
peeps that point our car Oh tell me skin
peeling me [ __ ] stop